what was going through my head at that
time I do not know I was drinking just
trying to take the pain away
it's tough man
[Music]
so that's a fantastic
hey that's football we'll call it man
united obviously it's all big and you
can have that control over you what
people have a voice Jesse he asked if we
could give him a couple of days off when
things are getting said about you that
it's not true he's gonna voice your
opinion I knew I needed to leave
do you have a suspicion why you won't
pick
um
you do don't you can see it in your face
so this is the whole thing what happened
is there a day that you look back on and
you go that was the hardest day
getting that much abuse and I'm already
down enough and I've got to perform I
was still trying to be Jesse like hey
like about no jokes on that but of
course it's gonna affect me
it's not done much at all this season
I've already gone through things when
you don't know about I felt like in the
world on my shoulders in 2019 your
mother was admitted Hospital
just kind of really cope anymore
did you ever figure out what the root
cause of your mother's Depression was
I think as soon as had me to be honest
[Music]
thank you for tuning in to watch this
episode honestly an incredible episode
but I have to say thank you before we
begin because we've hit a million
subscribers on this channel now and I
it's almost Unthinkable it's I can't you
know I'm speaking for our entire team
here when I say it's genuinely genuinely
Unthinkable biggest privilege of my life
to get to do this means the world that
you guys tune in every every week to
listen to these episodes roughly 65 of
you that watch this channel now
subscribe to the channel which is
amazing if you haven't yet subscribed
could you please do me a little bit of a
favor
um I can't tell you how much it helps
this Channel and how much it's helped us
to pull in amazing amazing guests and to
expand everything within our operations
and how it's also going to help us
enable the the year that's to come and
all the plans we have some huge plans
which I'm going to be bringing to you
very shortly really really hope you
enjoyed this episode thank you for being
here thank you for helping us reach this
huge master of a million subscribers
let's get on with it Jesse
[Music]
give me your context what is the take me
right back to when you were in those
early years as you signed and joined
Manchester United I think at seven years
old what was life like if I'd been in
your home if I'd been in your
surroundings in your environment what
was life like
um
life was good obviously Mormon does
split up
an early age especially when I was born
which can make things a lot difficult
um but I still had the the desire the
hunger
so going training we're going to taught
me in training you know week and week
out you know our trials are Everton City
Liverpool so I'm going to be driving up
and down the motorway
constantly
um
you know to support me and and take me
to training and games and then
obviously made a decision to sign up for
United at nine years old you know we had
a you know great team
um no one likes a Pogba
um Ravel in the team so we had a we had
a great team on
um I think outside of that obviously I'm
almost very supportive but that was very
supportive it was you know football mod
you know so I think that support system
especially at an early age is important
did everybody in your circle around you
have high hopes for your
for your career when you were that age
about 10 12 13 did they think you were
going to be a professional football
player oh my grandmother did your
granddad did yeah he
I mean was on their surf pretty much
every day
practicing skills learning new things
um and he had the the belief that would
be a footballer and you know if it
wasn't for him then you know it wouldn't
be in this situation I mean because he
took time out of his day to take me
enough to you know practice my brother
will come down but that will come down
you know we play One Touch
two top football you know pretty much on
a regular basis and that's my happy
place that's where I'm most happy on a
football pitch and like I say my grandma
was you know very important
you know part of me
into Liverpool into City into United on
Trials because you know people
recognized you know their talent but he
was there to push me I I was watching
the documentary and I saw
um
a Granddad who looked
it's rare to see I mean you one might
expect a dad or a mother to be that
pushy and direct and critical but to see
a grandad being that Savage with you at
times was quite surprising can you give
me a flip for anybody that hasn't seen
it can you give me a flavor of how
how um
tough he was at times
well he got he got he got banned a
couple of times
like when I say we're 12 years old or
playing stalk away
and he's come on the pitch after the
game and said you're not fit to wear a
shirt
so you're not fit to wear a shirt not
even if it's wearing a shirt
I'm thinking like the cop was just
looking at me I'm like I can't do
nothing he had me on weights at 10 years
old like lifting weights went into to
man united and said to won the coach's
tiny wheel at the time he said like you
know I want to get my grandson into it
because it obviously is a it was a power
lifter for a great burn right so you
know he wanted me on the way it's an
early early age to try and build a bit
of muscle because you know I was always
small he kind of drove that from you
know being a power lifter you know for
Great Britain
kind of pass it on to me and Mum was a
gymnast it's always kind of tough on her
as well mum took it
the wrong way
um because obviously she's got to be a
gymnast but we're gonna be so hard on
her that you know eventually she you
know she quit on that
um but even with me you know some games
I'd you know not play the best and
you know you get in the car on the way
home and you know I'll tell you that
look oh my toe was sore today like let's
try and make excuses because he saw like
hard on me but he was trying to push
like it come from a good place I'm
saying
so the reason why your mother quit
gymnastics was because he was so hard I
know yeah he was so so tough on her
um and obviously she didn't have really
the motivation to carry on
probably she went strong enough to to
carry on that but you know for me I I
was new to be a footballer so
you know have him you know my granddad
you know my Dad my mom around me at the
time you know trying to push me and it
was difficult even earlier stages
because you know I was living
literally five minutes but you know like
I said my mum couldn't
really cool with me at the time
um and I suppose back and forth from
another one that's a lot
and then like I say I see you driving
from up and down the motorway Liverpool
straight back to Manchester now I would
train at Liverpool for one day have a
game for United the next day so you know
he put the he put the yardage in you
know to get me well or what to eat today
you said you said that your mother
couldn't really cope with you at the
time what do you mean by that
it's depression
um
should be in bed all day
well most days
um
you know go in ask some money for the
ice cream
like still be in bed
so me I was I was happy to go lucky I
I'm bubbly like what's going to play out
with play football my friends
but and you don't understand
you know the situation that you know
your movies in at the time was so young
so I didn't really understand what was
going on
um until obviously it got it got brought
to light you know
Maybe
let's say
about 16 17 you can kind of understand
like what she's going through and and
things like well she'll never talk about
it I should always part it up so your
mother was
suffering from depression even when you
were very very young yeah but at that
time you just didn't realize what it was
no you didn't know it was did she know
what it was
I think she I think she knew yeah but
she would never
at that time would have really a support
system to support her [ __ ] I've really
people around her that you know she'll
go to like she can go to my PA now and
you know go to the doctors and you know
show us all out but at that time
obviously I think she knew what it was
but
she couldn't really caught with it she
can't really didn't know I had to deal
with certain things
um
and you know for me almost okay so I
always play out of fun play football but
for her
she's supposed to go be in bed like all
day she would she could drop me off at
school well she should go off at school
uh eight o'clock in the morning and then
sleep until three o'clock until she bits
me up
that's how bad it was
like she was we were really going for it
so she'd sleep all night wake up to drop
you to school and then go back to bed
yeah she sleep in the daytime
pick me up from school
probably go back to bed again just lay
in bed like cutting a short dark room
everything
and then
obviously you know buff me whatever go
before I go to bed and then she'll sleep
all night
over the last 10 years or so people have
become more aware of what like
depression and mental health is and this
is kind of why I ask if your mother knew
what it was because like 10 years ago if
I'm being completely honest there was a
real stigma around mental health it was
kind of seen as someone just kind of
being a bit crazy and over the last 10
years thankfully we've gotten to a point
where we have a better understanding
that we have physical and mental health
and this is why I say like did your
mother know what it was did she just
think she was just
sad or she didn't have motivation or did
she know she was depressed
yeah I think it was a pull in the
motivation part I just couldn't get out
of bed she's got motivate yourself to
get our bed
even when I woke up
I was dying for it to be there
and I think she came for the
quarterfinals
and that just made me so happy because
in that situation
you know not getting out of bed not
having a motivation but she find that
motivation to come and see her someplace
at World Cup
that was like I was I told her like I
was really part of her I was it's Brave
what he did because
you know every day in bed depressed no
motivation and just to find that little
bit of motivation just to come and see
you know a son that'll work up and don't
forget she's got you know I've got my
little sister and little brother as well
so
you know she's got to deal with them as
well
um which is always tough but like I say
to find that motivation to come and see
me at work what was
important for me especially because I
wanted to I want to live there anyway
regardless and I didn't even know she
was coming until I was in the lineup
singing national anthem for Messina
you've seen him really I know just give
me a Goosebumps straight away that was
so emotional after that and I wanted to
perform at the highest level and win the
game just for a I think there's a
there's a video on on my Instagram of me
hugging her for like
two three minutes I've seen it and it's
there's some things I can that can make
you happier you know as a person but
just to be there and get up and get
changed and get dressed
and have that motivation so not a World
Cup that's what made me happy
this is a bit of a difficult question
because it's not always obvious but did
you
did you ever figure out where
or what the root cause of your mother's
Depression was
um
not really no I think
I think as soon as she had me to be
honest I think it was just difficult for
her to
love and a child
um
you know took over most of the time but
you know she was still there she was
still a mother but
just hard for us to do over and
you know we had certain instances where
you know we would be in Ben should we
like trying to stretch my legs and that
like I'm like what's happening I didn't
know what was going on I didn't know she
had depression at the time also I was
such a young age
um but for it was just normal like
normal for her and she's like you know
stretching my life you got training
tomorrow and I'm like
oh what's going on like I didn't realize
what was going on so I shot them like
phases where you know should do
um
you know some
extraordinary you know stuff stretching
your legs I'm confused yeah it's like
like stretching my brains out like
before like we went to sleep
just like it was strange for me because
I knew I trained next day but
if I heard I was probably not like
natural normal
so I mean like I still don't still don't
resonate with me today I'm probably not
resonate with her today of what was
going through ahead at the time like
especially when I was born
like Gucci handle that situation of
having a kid so you're saying basically
before you would go to sleep she was
stretching your legs in a way that
didn't make sense like as in yeah I was
like I just want to go to sleep right
why well another question like I'm
another question but she was too like
astronomy stuff
and this lasted this has lasted up until
today since as young as you can remember
till till today
yeah
and I think she's just a lot she'll
still always have depression
but she can cope with it now she can
handle it because I've said we've got
the right support system around
but still it's
like I say I've got my little brother
and sister who she looked after and you
know what
just come on mum's come on lease some
bones to be honest
especially from like even a documentary
she was nervous to do that like she was
crying in the car like the director
sport tour I said you're going to be
involved in it she's crying like the
nervous she's caught with it
but you know she's found a courage final
motivation you know to do it and
that's still a big thing even though
she's going through what she's going
through
but like I say we can we can handle you
know certain situations now
emotions you said about bottling up your
emotions and generally you know
I think men in particular have a real
problem with kind of expressing their
emotions for various reasons because
we're you know we're Macho and masculine
and whatever else but
um did you learn at a young age at all
how to express your emotions did you see
did you have models in your life where
people were emotionally expressive
no
only with
only mum I'm an underground nod I would
always say love you like how are you
okay
but like that side
right not not much
like rally hog
more of a you know fist pump but you
know sometimes you want to see that
that love inside especially from you
know our father
and you know me becoming a five result
that's all I want to do with with hope
you know Express you know what emotions
or
um so I mainly got it from like my mum's
side Granddad none mainly
like say
I think it does come into a realization
where
you know we've seen a documentary and
you know as far as what's the point in
you know it's a short life what's the
point in
in arguing all the time because my mom
and dad never seen eye to eye so
I can understand from my mom's
perspective where
you know she don't want to see him but I
mean that's come to our realization
where it's like look
let's go together let's have a coffee
let's sit down you know documentary
really you know walking up and and
realize Life's too short to you know
because it becoming games and
my mom it'd be asking like this is your
window box so he's in the Box are you
using the box and I'm like my mum but
I'll I'll sit in the stands and and I
know it shouldn't be like that but you
know that's how it is but he wants that
you know to give in us again but I can
never see what I'm doing it
I never see them giving him time of days
to be honest
has your mom been able to find a new
partner since
she picks
yeah she picks um
not the best people to be honest
um she puts a lot on us this
but
she kind of fries off that for some
reason like the bad boys
and
you know the situation that we're in
you know you can't be
coming out with these guys and doing
what you're doing with these guys
because you know it comes back to me
they've had a lot of drama
with
most of them to be honest and
the last guy
hung himself
which is
it was deep
um
but it
you know what narcissists are like like
one minute you'll be given to the world
and then next to be like who you with
like he texting blah blah
I'm I'm speaking I'm like Mom these guys
are not good for you like they're not
good for you but some
somehow she thrives off them situations
and gets a buzz off it and becomes happy
so
I was in a situation where it's like
do you want me to be happy
um being with these guys or
you know bring her back down to earth
so it's a difficult situation but
like I say yeah the guy you know hung
himself in the end
um
and then
I think after that my mom realized
um you know she can't be you know dating
these people
it's difficult I completely relate to
what I can completely understand
not that I've had that lived experience
but I can understand what you're saying
with this conflict of I want her to be
with someone but if it's a bad option
would I rather her just be alone and
then you know
I was thinking as you were saying that
about many of my friends who have been
going through difficult situations with
their mental health and what ends up
happening because there might be a gap
somewhere or something missing or
something not quite stable with you you
end up attracting someone like a mirror
who is also a little bit
unstable or who isn't in the best place
and you're kind of are toxic together in
a way
and often I think with some of my
friends it's like you just need to work
on yourself first before you yeah you
try and find someone who you know
because a lot of the time we end up
trying to look for someone that will fix
us yeah which is never a good thing I
think that's what she she did
someone to
because you know she's not she's got
friends but she doesn't she don't go out
with her friends and you know be social
so
I feel like her having you know someone
uh
you know she could go to his house she
could do things with him she could be
happier
but on the other side it's like
that's they're not good for you at all
you know to bring they kind of bring you
down in a way manipulators and
manipulating and they're well aware of
you should believe it right she believed
like
like would I don't know would go
probably would go somewhere like me my
mom Daisy and maybe travel something or
something like that the guy was texting
like where are you like what are you
doing who you with all right what's your
family no you're not no you're not no
you're not yeah and it's like
I don't know my mom's like dealing with
this and I'm like how can you deal with
that
I'm thinking how can you deal with this
and let's block him
but she just like she loves the
attention she loves it narcissists
Target people like that that they can
control in such a way be coercive and
manipulate and sort of take advantage of
their self-esteem and stuff that's what
narcissists do because an individual
like that a narcissist like that would
never
be successful in coercion and
manipulation of
um someone who would go what the [ __ ]
are you texting me when I'm with my
phone the [ __ ] do you think they
wouldn't they wouldn't survive there so
they find that they find their way to
people who they can easy targets yeah
exactly his Target
if I say like looks leave him she's like
yeah yeah I'll block him block him look
she'll unblock him the next day
tough man
it's difficult it's hard
it's difficult
difficult difficult thing
um off you go into to Manchester United
um when did you when did you get in your
view your first real break in Manchester
um
Apollo and Jose are coming really yeah I
mean not in the South it's relaxed
Ferguson
I'll make it when I'm 23. I'm 23 24. so
you know I always believed enemy always
believed in me
um I think when they were always coming
I went ready to play first team football
yet
and then I think
especially on the van Gogh
um
you know gave me the confidence to play
but
still it was difficult because
you know I was at a stage where
played the first game on the van Gogh
the money six months out
January came
went online to Derby
and then the season after that was that
kind of make our break
so I left it till
October
time
and if I weren't playing then then I
knew I needed to leave
and then
he played me at CSK Moscow way Champs
League
like starting what's up okay
freezing cold minus five whatever it was
really was like don't wear gloves
like what is that don't wear gloves
that's okay
I don't wear gloves played well
and after that stayed in the team so
it's kind of a that's kind of a make-up
break time for me why is that comment
don't wear gloves significant
to you
because
you know especially at United we're
brought up
go wear black boots
no gloves
no long bombs in training just like the
basic things we brought up with that so
when you go into the first team of
course in the warm-up you don't want to
wear clothes
but for the game you know Back to Basics
how we grew up
don't wear gloves in the game
it's about values right it says values
you know it's morals it's the way you've
been brought up you know United
put that into us an early age
a lot of that comes from Sir Alex
Ferguson right I'm super you know I've
sat here with a bunch of extra Alex
Ferguson players Rio Gary Patrice
how would you describe the um the
culture at Manchester United during that
Sir Alex Ferguson period what was the
culture like
it was good yeah always but a real
scoozy gigsy
um you're not always but not even on
tour
um you know it's good to go on tour of
them and you know I think
you know real being real always was
there for advice I always had to speak
to
um you know on a regular basis like
Muslim schools are the same
um were they honest and critical as well
though are they tough
some of those senior Lads
um
yeah because the winners
and you know they've been there and done
that and you know did one trophies
before and
you know it was unfortunate that I went
in you know any of the teams that you
know won the Prem or are Champs league
but you know even on tour it was you
know you still win games and
you know going on tour with them
especially with you know so Alex was you
know an amazing feeling remember being
on a bench me and Pogba got called up
for
it's about to manage against Newcastle
you'll not knowing if I'm gonna play or
not but still just to be there and see
how you know they are in a change of
room and you know see that winning
mentality and
I think being at United is all you know
it's
been installing you from a young age you
know winning is important talk about how
you win
just win and I think they've been so
successful in over the years
um you know winning trophies
just by having that winning mentality
celex Ferguson leaves
now it's funny because I'm a Manchester
United fan I'm a big fan and I've had
season tickets over the years and
um go to most of the games at home still
today
and it and from what I've heard it went
from being like a like a family
to
being run by Ed Woodward and it feeling
less like a family like one of the
comments one of the waitresses meant
said to me was you know when Sir Alex
Ferguson and David Gil were here they
would come in here and like chat to us
and they knew all of our names every
single one of our names and then when
Silas Ferguson left one of them said to
me they don't beat it they don't speak
to us anymore it's different I
so Alex was like month a month
like
when we're training with the first year
bring us all right 16 17 train with the
first team like they give you that
confidence know your names know all like
from probably
under tens
to the first team it's not everyone's
name
you take this time out to understand you
as a person or saying your family
and like I say you know things change
[Music]
um
you know but with him
you know it was good that you know if
you could understand the family side get
to know your family a bit more
um you know understand you as a person
you'll see a progression like I say you
said 23 34 you'll be in the first team
you know to head up you know you can
kind of get a big eagle but you know for
me it was nothing's guaranteed anyway
so I'm just gonna work my ass off 10
times you know more you know so being
that first team
Rio said to me that when his granddad
was Ill Sir Alex Ferguson not only knew
but he knew what um Rio's Grandad's
favorite whiskey was flowers were and he
sent it to the hospital bed before
anybody else he got it there so Rio said
to me whenever I've asked the senior
players why stuff was so good they all
said they would all just before you even
get the words out they'd say man
management that's what you said though
and I think I think even this day and
age now
I feel like it's important
even with Josie Josie used to FaceTime
me like randomly
a couple times I'll be driving and be
FaceTiming me I'm like where are you
where you kid
I'm just driving home within salvages
where's Marcus
I don't know everything is at home okay
enjoy
just little things I little calls here
on there even you know Steve Cooper not
gonna ring me let's have conversations
wanting to understand you a little bit
more very soon so I think I feel like
it's so important why
because it shows that they care it shows
and when they care you care back yeah
right okay it works yeah like I'll
understand you a little bit more than
you know as a person not just as a
person like how are you like how you
operate
not in football I want no outside of
football as well
same with the lads like one way outside
of football I get to know your families
and I think
well I learned that from was England
we've got a soft gate
money management top
got to the 2018 World Cup got to the
rooms
see a picture of them me and my mum
see a picture
me and Marcus
right home
so when you got to your room at Camp
yeah
in the hotel
like I thought I was at home
he really has got the best out of
England in my in my lifetime in the 30
odd years that I've lived I've never
seen an England side that looks so happy
and cohesive and honestly ego free
um and then it's showing in the in the
tournaments we're playing we have hope
like I was I was out in Katana I was in
the stadium for the England France game
and even though we lost it I walked away
happy because we're playing great and
we're challenging what's he done in your
view
um to that England side to to create
that atmosphere in that culture
I don't think he understands
you know others players I think
when he first came in he was the first
person to give him a debut of England
I played with him on the 21s you know on
the studies values and and the way he
did things
and then you know coming into you know
the senior team you know give him a
debut what are his values New View
um
I mean he cares about the players a lot
and
like I say he wants to understand you
know the player
um
you know so for me you know being from
it on a 21 level and obviously being
with a senior team
you know this this trust already there
anyway
but
you know it takes a lot to trust a
person and
you know for someone new coming into the
team
um
you know we still understands the person
and like I say he wants that trust and
the trust back on
you know you can speak about anything
not just football it's about anything
and you know we'll understand and I'll
ask about oh how's your mum how's your
dad this little things go a long way and
I think you know the money management
side of it
is is very important especially
tournaments anyway
but
you know the group was a collective you
know understand is his values and the
way he does things
um you know so people knew coming to
come you know it's easy selling shall we
because it'll pull you straight away and
like speak to you and set you down and
you know talk just talk and that's it
and I think it's so important what is
you know a lot of managers are known for
you know sir Alex Ferguson's one of the
trademarks of his style is the hairdryer
I know that's kind of like over gas by
the media and stuff because you hear
what
um a caring man he was but when you
think about Southgate style compared to
these other managers you've had like van
Gala Mourinho and all and Moyes Etc
what's his style South Gates
it's different but it's still got the
the hair dryer I don't know really yeah
yeah it surprises a lot of people
but
you need that though because
you know our manager is you know nice
and unless you you know get away with a
lot of things here and there like he's
he's on it I will tell you if you're in
the wrong way or not
I don't know what what player you are
who you are it'll tell you something
wrong or not
but
you know another hand is still
he still wants to create that good vibe
you know with a team and
you know he'll shot one
you know it's needed but most of the
time it's just you know simple you can
speak to him you know we'll speak to the
group
um you know simple words
you know enjoy the game with you know
we've been here before
go out go out win the game you know have
fun do the tactics all in the week but
you know it's not something like that
you know he's a good guy as well
I think you know it goes a long way
especially you know with England team
quick one as some of you know Intel are
sponsoring this podcast and for me Intel
has made the search for a premium laptop
so much easier by creating the Intel Evo
platform which is signified by this
sticker here in the corner laptop
designs only receive the Intel Evo badge
when they have been tested to pass Intel
Zone very strict requirements so that
they can actually perform as you need
them to out in the real world and the
result for me is a premium laptop that
can perform everywhere even with my
crazy schedule in mind and most
importantly it can handle multiple tabs
open and a battery that really lasts
throughout the entirety of my meetings
whenever you need your laptop for Intel
Evo have you covered it's a game changer
to find out more and to get your hands
on an Intel Evo laptop go to intel.co.uk
Evo and let me know how you get on it is
that time of year again when my life
becomes incredibly reliant on Hill I'm
busier than ever I'm trying to be
nutritionally complete in all that I do
I'm trying to make sure I get all of the
vitamins and minerals that I need in my
diet and heal has been for the last
three and a half years the primary
reason as it relates to my diet that
I've been able to be nutritionally
complete while also being incredibly
productive they've also been a sponsor
of this podcast since we launched the
podcast and so I owe them a huge debt of
gratitude for enabling this show and in
fact when we hit the million Milestone
on YouTube with this podcast I sent it
to the founder because I've never shared
this before but he actually said to me
when I started the podcast he was like
you're gonna absolutely kill it you'll
have millions of subscribers you'll be
this big you'll be that big so many
people will listen and I don't know if I
believed it if I'm being completely
honest but he believed in Us in this
show
um before we'd released one episode
which is a remarkable thing and he gave
me a huge amount of self-belief in
myself so thank you Julian Hearn for
that but also thank you huel for
creating a product that has helped me
and help my health stay intact in my
busiest days over the last couple of
years
why did Manchester United not reach the
levels on the pitch during that era
because when I look at the players that
we had I mean [ __ ] hell we signed
some unbelievable players it's not
people often criticize the glazes for
lots of reasons but when you think about
the money spent on players on the pitch
we spent the money yeah it's like Oh Mr
Billy I think it's almost a billion
billion billion we spent in players in
that period yet we couldn't we couldn't
seem to win we couldn't seem to get that
cohesion right through that sort of van
Gaal Mourinho era and even the David
moyzera
um what's your assessment on why that is
like what why wasn't it
I think it didn't click of course it won
you know with Vanguard when the FA Cup
when we know Europa League
Cowboy cop
could these these world-class players
are coming to United and I'll be honest
they're looking average
so they would come from a club where
they were banging and me and my friends
we celebrate our Manchester United chat
we're like here we go Lads every year
and then it's like they'll become half
the player
it's strange because a lot of players
have come in unveiled
like I say oh
you know relaxing training
top
like this this is
quality training quality
when it comes to a game this thing clip
for some reason not on
is it pressure
you know when I was playing especially
with Roman
you know Alexis we decided to enjoy
football and of course it's gonna be
hard to win a premise if you know been
so dominant for for many years but even
to win Europa League you know carabao
cup Community Shield
like we're winning trophies but
I think when
Jose left and trophy stopped
that's difficult
another new manager
it's kind of like you
you have to like kind of prove yourself
over and over again
it's kind of like you know
false like fake promises really I think
that's what the heart of it yeah like
you know you get I I you're doing more
like you know you're playing this game
not playing during the time under social
yeah because I've played at first and
then obviously when when all first came
in you know unbelievable you were all in
out of control that's what I'm saying
yeah and then
I said to me before the season you know
if I don't play
x amount I gained before December and we
let me go alone in January he said yeah
so then play and generally come West Ham
came in and install people wolves you
know debating you know is he fair enough
is he ready to to go into a team like
that and start straight away that nearly
didn't happen did it it was off and on
and off and on
honestly
I literally with my brother
watching Skies what's news
Dave always on the phone I'm like yeah
I'm coming I'm there like you want me
down there
edible Rings no you're not going there
it's off it's done
it's crying I was crying
me and bro just crying I was like to do
is play football
it was
all right it's back on now yeah
I do is play football let me let me just
go and play football please
as soon as I got there hit the ground
running
that's probably one of my best seasons
to be honest
like I think nine goes five assists in
from like February to May
I still didn't go Euros after that
and that was a main integral Euros how
did that feel when you found out that
you won't go in after having one it
probably arguably your best ever year in
football before at West Ham when you
were you know widely considered to be
the most informed player in the league
how did it feel
it's heartbroken because
you know
growing up I was what I do represent my
country
and play for England
and
to not play
the first half of the season
than to go to West Ham
on the phone I was in there quite easy
took it into into the orals but
didn't pick me like I say weren't strong
enough to probably say
look why I'm not picked well that's
helped probably yeah what do you think
yeah like
what what I could have done to get into
this yeah should I score 10 11 12 goals
I don't know do you have a suspicion why
you weren't picked
um you do don't you I can see it in your
face no because
I could see that smirk you do I don't
know because
I was thinking of
form
how how can I not be picked do you think
it could be something else
because your form you can't argue with
it can't argue for him
off the pitch
off the picture was sweet I was in a
good mental space so I don't know what
it could have been then
this is what I'm saying who knows and
maybe
one day we'll probably get
you know the reason
but to this day
not sure why
in 2019 as as shown in the documentary
your mother was admitted Hospital
what was what was
what was the cause of that
of that happening what was the lead-up
of events that sent her to hospital
just a depression it was just so bad
that
she couldn't really cope anymore and
I think she needed to go away and get
help
but
then leaving me with
my little sister who was probably 11 at
the time and
you know my little brother who's
probably like 15 at the time
for me I was still going through my own
things as well
so
I went really the the big bro that they
wanted at the time
because they always get like
the phone The Laffy Jesse the bubbly
Jesse
by that time I was going for my own
stuff anyway so I was just autopilot
your mum's in hospital you've got two uh
younger siblings that you're now primary
carer of and how are things going on the
pitch you're saying that you just
weren't present on Pitch
swear now like
mentally
went there
like I'd be on a pitch but
still my mini pitch really yeah I don't
want to play I Don't Wanna I don't want
to quit football
I've never quit football but
I would have needed a break if a lot
down income wouldn't need a break 100
and is this in this is an old first year
or second year
yeah it's like the second year on
almost gone into games I
smile bluntness
it's not up here it's just like I didn't
want to be an ass but it's all
of course I'm gonna play about and then
you're getting abuse
that was kind of what tips it over to be
honest
after the Derby game what happened
so we won
but you know as soon as you get on the
bus it's no Jesse [ __ ]
blah blah like why are you playing froze
blah blah
and
she fell at Luke shot back to be honest
he came down off the bus and I started
shouting I'm arguing whatever but don't
be friends or United fans but
like I'm human I mean of course it's
gone off at me like I'm already down
enough anyway
I'm already going through things what
you don't know about
and I've got to perform on a weekly
basis
and when you're performing you're not
performing it 100
so of course it's going to be critics
and you know you're not playing that
well
to be abused like that
it's kind of what kind of what tips with
her
that was like I was like no I can't this
is I can't be asked anymore
like I need I need a break I need to
find something some motivation some fire
in my belly again
to get going again because you know I
can't can't be doing this I
might be another game next week and I'll
be like Oh I'm like just can't be
awesome I can't I don't want to play
just during that time that time period
of everything what was going on mum look
after my little brother and sister when
I I felt like underwear on my shoulders
there's this really kind of like moving
haunting part in the documentary where
I think you broke your older brother has
Louis had videoed you lying on the sofa
completely yeah still your eyes are like
blank that's how it was
like
even at training like just masking it
just
my skin you know the depression side of
things
the anxiety
like I was still trying to be Jesse like
yeah a bunch of jokes or not but
you know it comes to a point where
you actually need to say something
because I felt like
the world was on my shoulders and
had no one sent to like can't speak to
anyone about anything I didn't want to
speak to another I thought you know what
I can deal with this I can handle this
I'm good enough to deal with this but
come to a point where
it's like look Ollie
this is what's going on
we kind of kept it
in all close-knit to be honest but even
just to have like Ollie say like you
know how's your mom how is she doing
like I could have a conversation with
him kind of a conversation with a kind
of conversation with liaison woman and
that has helped a little bit more
just having done a conversation and
letting people understand like what I'm
going through
and then I think I did it I did a piece
for the paper
um you know talking about and
I still don't think people really fully
understood you know what was going on
until until like like I said documentary
came out
in order for you to
um
be able to have those conversations with
the people you first had to make the
decision to like for you to talk about
how you're feeling because once you open
up then they can give you that support
you talked about how it's difficult to
do that when you're a young man did you
realize in that moment that you were
suffering with depression could you see
see yourself and your mother
oh yeah probably yeah
I think the video sums up the woman want
to solve for I'm actually Layla for like
three minutes
just staring to finish I don't know what
I was thinking don't know what's going
for my head at the time but I could say
like I was I was I was drinking
something like that like before bed like
having nightcaping like it's not about
nothing
I'm not doing that far
all right what I need is something
just trying to take the pain away
and like put me at ease somehow I'm like
trying to forget what's going on but it
makes 10 times worse
do you feel the online criticism do you
are you exposed to it
no don't read it you don't read it no
have you ever gone on Twitter and looked
at what people are saying no I think
that's the worst thing anyone can do
some players must do that though right
players do it yeah but I don't know why
because
see if I'm strong enough to handle it
now yeah I
I'm showing a tangled negative comments
criticism whatever
concentrating football there's no point
going in Search and Phil yeah in a sewer
yeah there's no point why search for it
because I'm thinking about like you know
we talked a lot recently about players
like Harry MaGuire being on the
receiving end of a lot of criticism and
stick
in My Views most of it's completely
unjust
um but
I've always wondered if players actually
feel that criticism and it impacts their
game
yeah I think so can you see that when
you're in the dressing room if you know
a place like been slammed in the press
or online or whatever can you see
them drop like their head drop a little
bit and then yeah they probably try and
mask it a little bit yeah
just to like be strong like I can't
handle it but
something like we are human
of course criticism is going to affect
us especially when you know the pundits
are saying it and it's
especially them you know with a pundit
saying it more than you know a comment
on Instagram or
[Music]
um
or any social media because it gets
highlighted more you know when the Press
with
um you know a pundit saying that's all
of course you're gonna see it or
someone's gonna send it here
but then it's kind of masking it trying
to be strong
and then you gotta go and perform but
I think the majority of players you know
in this day and age are strong enough to
know what anyone says anymore
you you did perform when you went to
West Ham you really really performed as
we've discussed
um I think a lot of people were
expecting you to stay there because you
performed so well and it just seemed
like you finally found your your groove
consistent you scored the goals you've
got the assists
what was your thinking at that point
when that loan comes to an end did you
want to stay at West Ham you wanted to
stay yeah Manchester United when did you
come back
yeah so I had a year
yeah I went into my final year after
that then
and I still wanted to go on I wanted to
go online and
John because I weren't playing again
so
Newcastle was on the cards in June deal
with donor FM
obviously the United Squad weren't big
enough
so let a couple players got online
and then when it comes to me
John irungu was like no like you're not
going alone
I was like um
well he's gonna know he's got let me
score an enjoy if I'm not playing there
so let me just go online all right let
me play football to Newcastle yeah
and um
[Music]
he's like what do you want days off I
was like no that's what I'm gonna play
football all right would you want days
off yeah so this is the whole thing what
happened
so then
to stop the loan obviously I was pissed
um
and then when he said about the days off
or not
I messaged him I was like you know what
I'm gonna take two days off now
just because you said that
so then they put out
um Jesse's last for two days off in the
media what went on Twitter straight away
no I didn't ask for two days off
he asked me the open days I was put I'll
put it out there the facts
how how what was the dressing room like
at that point you know when because a
lot of players would obviously when all
Ronaldo comes in obviously all
eventually ends up getting fired et
cetera Etc
um
it did feel like you know they use this
phrase or the managers lost the dressing
room or there's from a fan looking in
you could just see that there was
something wrong with the culture at the
club players would come in there that
were world-class as we said earlier
world-class else were coming they were
becoming [ __ ] average players you
know you've got all of these these
rumors leaking you've got all of this
stuff happening players at the club
feeling like their trust has been broken
like you said you've been lied to a few
times it just felt like some there was
no someone didn't have control of the
place no it won't there's no control I
don't think like you say when Sir Alex
was there it was full control like a
fortress yeah
Fortress everything goes for him
contracts everything like commercials
like everything
of course Generations change
players grow up people have a voice what
like you say when
things are getting said about you that's
not true
you're gonna voice your opinion like say
what happened back in the day it'd be
squashed there and then with Sir Alex
but like you say no
people have got platforms to to voice
their own opinion and write what they
want do you think players have lost lost
respect not in this sort of um Eric Tana
gear but just in that period that
followed through these managers and the
Soul share if you think players from
what you'd seen had kind of lost respect
for the club
probably uh it looked like that yeah
probably it looked like this wasn't
there
the same control you know control right
there's no there's no structure there's
no there's no balance for people doing
what they want pretty much on it it's
like a free throw
yeah it's just a free throw I mean
like you say
people saying something like
that's never happened ever
at United
people are sending stuff onto a run I
think up in the parliament as well
like you've got a lot of scrutiny all
right guys one of the best midfielders
in the world like
I've known him since like 16.
like she kids Got Talent one like he's
one of the best midfielders in the world
and still he can't perform at United
so there's something wrong
in some way
you got one of the best midfielders in
the world you can't perform and then
during the season when you're in
National Grid and he goes to France
let me see how he plays the fronts
it's like
yeah guy's sick
let me come back like
Alexis or not I told you
I don't know what it is I don't know
what I can't say what it is I don't know
what it is
I enjoyed my time on the draws either
like I'd want one of my best seasonal
drills later I was gonna I'm gonna say
that of all these managers van Hal you
know Mourinho oh in the in movies in a
post solex folk scenario when did it
most feel like there was control and
that United was starting to be more like
United
um probably Vanguard to be honest really
yeah
a
yellow structure
like everyone understood what he wanted
like some people didn't like I love Van
Gogh
um very tactical knew I wanted to play
and everyone bought into that
and then of course Josie
best manager in the world just wants to
win
but like you say had that mind
management as well and had the belief in
me and the trusting me to perform
if you could waive a one then if I give
you one then I said okay
in that all era in that post Alex
Ferguson era do one thing
to fix
the club's issues what would you have
done with that one
wish have been you know what it is I
think uh the saw behind
on like with everything
like
you see like six facilities see
tottenham's facilities when we go there
a lot of England and that one between
left on them
like people on Mars head
even like like the social side of things
and I went to him like tivan so eating
about like YouTube and let's do like
content
now they're so behind on everything
I just want him to just get up to date
on like the new things are happening
like the things that are popping what
does that matter
you gotta be relevant you gotta stay
relevant but in terms of like the
training ground it obviously Ronaldo and
appears Morgan interview talks about the
jacuzzi and the the chefs and the food
and the facilities and the weights
training equipment and he left years ago
yeah he says he came back and it was all
the same yeah
how does what impact does that have when
you as a player
you want the best things you want
especially like you know it's one of the
biggest clubs in the world so you know
you want the best for the best and
you know of course you want the best
food on
um you know you want a swimming pool and
the jacuzzi in this island which is it's
still there but
you know it's like
um modern like
modernized because
like you see like you know cities
facilities or not
and like you think like I'm like
black girl today like catch up a little
bit like because like you're way behind
at the moment
is it is a symbolic thing like as in
it's just a it's kind of a symbol that
you're not keeping up with the other
clubs you're not investing in the in the
small stuff which as a player you go
well then
well we're also behind on the pitch and
we're just behind just down in general
because
like back in the day we have like tables
on a table and like
um like pool and everything
so like you like mentally you know happy
and you know with a dart ball and stuff
like but
nothing
and like just just go in you train and
you go home
sometimes you are like stay at a
training ground sometimes
you know play that sort of lads and you
know play table tennis for the boys or
not
but
this is like like I say just need to
catch up a little bit more and I'm
becoming a little bit more modern
because he changed like the canteen or
not but
you know to
to be relevant and stay in this day and
age you know you've got to be more a
little bit more modern
is that because of the the ownership is
that the like the people at the top of
the club just don't understand what's
important for the players because they
spent their money on players but to hear
that they didn't spend the money on
things behind the scenes kind of speaks
to the fact that I don't know because
Sir Alex Ferguson probably could have
called the shots back in the day and
said we need this we need this we need
this we need this
whereas these days
don't know what's going on
and of course now they want to sell the
club
what the fans have been wanting them out
for you know a long time but did the
players care did the players take a view
do you think
um
not red it was just like I say just
behind was just behind
on a lot of things
um
let me tell you what you want that
modern you want the modern things
you want the things that are
you know popping off at that time
but I don't know
like who called the shots about you know
changing the training ground or
on things a lot but
like I say just just to catch up a
little bit and let me see what what city
you're doing on that right so
frustrating round
best facilities
no one talking back in the Press
about the about the team you um you
chose after your timer
um Old Trafford after your contract to
come to an end to go to Nottingham
Forest a lot of people were surprised by
that a lot of people would have thought
you would have gone to back to West Ham
where you'd had an unbelievable run or
even to Newcastle or something like that
why why did you choose Nottingham Forest
newly promoted team
they've just been promoted right yeah
um
why why Forest
I finished all the love
to show
you know the Wilderness and the hunger
to want me
dude Who's Gonna Fly me here and
everywhere to
to get a deal Over The Line
um
things brought down at West Ham
negotiations
which obviously I can't get into too
much but
no I'm not even showed
the love
a lot more than
you know West Ham and
you know when you think about it you
know I've been at West Ham anyway before
and you expect
like you see what I can do I'll see what
I've done so you expect him to be like
yeah like you know what I will show you
the love like
this is the contract blah blah let's
negotiate let's talk
it went like that for some reason they
didn't want you to sign no they want me
to sign them kind of rush it it's like
kind of rushed
like it'll be like Wednesday and be like
Sunday Friday like there's a deal let's
let's talk like you know me
like I'm not respect yeah like it's just
show a little respect like I've been
there I've helped your team like we've
got got to Europa League
I show a lot a bit more respect on that
well nothing I'm just like listen
like we love y'all
we want your all right the manager will
come to your house
like the owner wants to fly you to
Greece like sand deal like doing
everything in the power to get the the
level alone
on
you know for me it's a new challenge
different challenge
another team of course I've known All
the known as United all my life
um
and I remember leaving
United
the last day
and
the physio that we had from under 18s
obviously is with the first team now
he's like I remember the FA Cup goal I
believe you've got you know run when you
when you won you've caught like I'll
always remember that goal like yeah
I was like
you know I'm leaving leaving crying all
the way home on that like couldn't
continue on emotions or not and then
like it lasted a long time like I've
been there all my life
like I know everyone in the club
from like staff kipman
thinner ladies
you know
Mike Glennie who scouted me you know to
United and like that that's been my life
United
but how did you feel about the club when
you left it
did you feel let down like disappointed
yeah a little bit
they say false promises here and uh
not really give you a reason why you
know you went playing
so yeah kind of let down to be honest
like say didn't really get a sand off
we've been there that long
I think I deserve one but when you get
in that car or you when I've been in the
moment it's all worth like I've you know
quit my business that I'd started seven
years in when there's hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
employees and my first reaction I got to
be honest was like I was like when I
knew I was going to quit I was so mad
and I wrote this email and it was kind
of bitter and whatever else when I
realized I was actually going to send
this email there was this little pause
and this is when I was in I was in
Portugal at the time and I got really
emotional yeah because that's when you
look back and go I'm actually going here
yeah like a hit shot yeah it's all said
and done now yeah and I'm I'm leaving
and so I've redid the email and it was
like a really nice one it was like a
thank you to like the board and stuff
for taking the chance on me and stuff so
yeah it's tough tough though because
that was tough when he said that when a
physio said that
I was gone I was gone crying all the way
home in the car
and people don't know that
like people probably thought like oh
yeah he's like he's happy silly but I
needed to leave
I wasn't playing
so why am I gonna like I got for the
contract but
what's the point I'm not gonna play so
I wouldn't rather
like yeah biggest club in the world but
happiness is more important for me and I
needed to be happy and go somewhere I'm
loved on
it's been a difficult start to the
season for Nottingham on the pitch
um as we sit here now I believe there in
the relegation Zone in the table
what's your what's your view on the
start of the year for Nottingham
I think it's always going to be tough
especially with new players coming in I
think 22-23 yeah crazy
so it's always going to be tough but
I feel like
I feel like especially the Tottenham
game The Palace game you know we started
getting a bit more momentum
everyone knows you know the rules and
responsibilities now we played with each
other
um you know a lot more and you know we
understand each other a lot more so I
felt like
you know the connection was especially
Tottenham and the palace game and then
obviously now we've had a break but I
think they break and doors does go to
regroup and
you know really you know reevaluate and
you know see what
what the main aim is for the season and
you know of course we don't bring my
location so you know we won't be winning
games on a way we need to do a lot
better
because
um you know we're struggling away from
home at the moment but you know home
games can be really crucial on key
because the atmosphere is
nothing I've like I've never heard it
like before I've never been a nightmare
feel like that for the game like Etc I
got goosebumps every time
and I feel like we need to really
I think this big D I think everyone
knows what the situation I'm in anyway
on just about
you know
maintain and keep working hard
because the attackers have got to score
and you know we've got to do our job
um
you know it's different from me because
you know I've been playing United and
you know of course we have all the ball
and you know we're getting shots and
chances on that of course it's gonna be
difficult I'm not even where you know
you might not see the wall as much and
you're not getting as many shots and
you're not create as many chances but
you know I thrive off these moments and
these and these challenges it's a new
challenge and
you know I'm happy to be there
um you know I love training I love I
love playing playing in the games and
that's the most important just to be
happy for me
off the pitch you know you're 29 now
players I think the average age of a
player usually goes I don't know 32-ish
I don't know
what are you thinking about off the
pitch what's going on in your world I
know you've got your you've got your
brand you're doing several Investments
and sort of deals you've got a media
company give me a view of what what that
looks like
so even you know I don't I've always you
know off the pitch I've always I'm
always on the go I always want to know
what the next thing is to do
what's the next investment what can I be
involved in what can I do Esports comes
gaming love gaming
Esports team let's do Esports team
brand love fashion that's so brand
at the launch for the Brandon was like
it was amazing I feel like 3 000 people
turned up like Victoria Warehouse
and then at the night time
little baby was there we've got a little
baby to perform
anyway even big big then
um
but I just wanna
I just want to be happy and do things
like
I want to do to make me happy
and
you know the investment the business
side of things
of course I want to set up things
from my little sister from my little
brother
for my daughter when she grows up like
they can just go into straight away and
I think with the media company
um it's called One Touch
and guess what it's got one touch
uh because you play one touch with your
granddad mm-hmm
something at One Touch
um and obviously the channel 4
documentary came from from Latin
I feel like it's just easier because
if I do a commercial now
JBL commercial
and
they're getting their production
but I can be like well you can use my
production then
like the talent can get paid
um Productions you can get paid at the
same time
so it's a win-win and all the con like
anything that we do that we
um video record we get last like final
say so anyway so it's all under our
umbrella
and like I say after football I want to
go into acting
so
maybe starting this now and
maybe start doing a little bit of voice
over work and like you know reanimation
kind of thing
um but I need to say drama classes I've
not done that yet why acting so when you
think about your life after football
some people think about being a pundit
or a manager or a coach whatever you're
thinking acting yeah how come
this is all films man I just I've always
been a big film lover
and
you know to be involved in
you know a film or a series would be you
know be amazing and
like I say I need to
to really you know
home in on on the drama side of things
and you know learn like I'm really bad
Reliance to be honest what would be your
dream role have you got an idea in mind
for what
um what kind of like acting
let's give me an example
I think I'm gonna start comedy comedy
I'm gonna start comedy first
and then
you know when you see the interstellars
and the inceptions
them kind of rules but that's going to
take time like you're not going to be
you're not gonna be thrown in straight
away
maybe a bit part here and there but you
know for the for the for the future with
with a media company I've got so many
things you know in in the lineup and
obviously it's based in LA and that's
where
eventually hopefully I want to finish
football
you want to finish in America yeah I
think so
at the very center of your documentary
is the story of your mother
I found this
wonderful picture
what does she mean to you
no she's everything mom
like she's been through it Mom
she's been for written
you know to see where she like where she
is today
from where she was
huge progression
so proud of her
and it can be hard because she's had
depression for years and years he is
like so he's having me probably made
that worse for him
because she couldn't probably handle
you know being them over at that time
but luckily we had you know we're not
going at that suppose but
what you want for him
that's one of the best for her
I wanted to see you know our kids grow
up
I know she's so proud of me I've
you know how far I've come
you know she'll still message me for my
bad game or I think like which is good
same like my granddad saying my dad
saying brother
[Music]
um
but yeah she's been through it but
that's not the best friend like I said I
wanna
you know keeping a
in this lifetime long enough to
you know see me progress see hope
progress into the character up what
she's gonna turn into because she's a
character at the moment you're proud of
her
mum yeah massively
massively how come
just uh
from saying in bed
you know the age I was there probably
although maybe a little bit older
not being social
to
FaceTiming me every day and ringing me
every day and just what you're doing and
have it
I love that
and I think my little sister like
she's 14 but she's acts like she's 18.
but
I think she she helps my mom as well a
lot
which is good because mum never really
had someone to
like lean on like not even men like not
even me Granddad really that much
like she's she's not really a darker pop
a friend to lean on you know in times of
struggle but I think I've been Daisy
there you know my little sister
you know she's she's really helped me
mum and I think my mom you know thrives
off that and
[Music]
why would you like honestly if you had a
camera Arrow so let's leave this is it's
24
seven Carnage
honestly
I believe you we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest asks a question for the next guest
without knowing who they're leaving the
question for
um the question that's been left for you
is
what are the uncomfortable things that
you banish to the Shadows which means
kind of putting the Shadows which would
improve your life
if you
integrated
them
basically means what are the things that
you put in the shadows that would
improve your life if they weren't in the
shadows I guess
so I think just to question things a
little bit more
because
you know growing up on I've never never
do that like
I've been put in situations where I
could question things like corn last
question
you don't actually not yet
but I've never done that and
you know it's only taught me
over these last couple of years where
you know confinedly
like man open you know be strong enough
to ask a question
because sometimes like sometimes it can
take time for you know a person to
you know to grow up and you know be a
mum but
you know having my daughter like change
a lot of things and
you know like I say things don't go your
way of course I want to question you
know things but back in the day I would
never
well Jesse thank you thank you um so
many reasons you've given me so much joy
as a Manchester United fan
um over the years I've I've you know not
just because of your off the field on
the field performance but just generally
like the personality you've brought into
the game and the happiness you bring to
your game
um but also the documentary you've
released on channel four
is incredibly important incredibly
inspiring because it's starting a new
wave of conversation around players
mental health and really a call for
empathy because we never as fans know
what's going on out off the pitch behind
the scenes and to have a view into that
puts puts things in perspective it kind
of turns the lights on and when you can
see that full picture hopefully people
will realize as you've said that your
your players you're not robots and that
even one comment or one thing happening
at home can like all of us like the rest
of us human beings kind of have a really
debilitating impact on us our mental
well-being and how we perform and that's
a really important conversation one that
you didn't need to to start
one that you could have very easily just
kept yourself and it's um tremendously
strong uh contrary to popular opinion
um to speak out like that especially
when you're a man and it's not so easy
to do so because of the stigma so thank
you for that that's incredibly important
and I'm exceptionally excited to see in
the next chapter of your life play out
at Nottingham Forest but then much
further on Beyond as you as you embark
on a new career in a different industry
thank you means a lot to me that you've
got me appreciate it Stephen pleasure
[Music]
quick one from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]